[Music]
[Applause]
Brady Quinn Fox college football analyst
former Notre Dame quarterback NFL
quarterback the big noon kickoff crew in
Vegas Pac-12 title game tonight eight
Eastern between Utah and USC not much on
the line for this one huh Brady
I don't know if I'd put it that way but
yeah as of right now here in Vegas that
in later than last night what some
people Dan would call God's country uh
other people call it Sin City it depends
on which side of the spectrum you're on
there but uh this is a must win in my
opinion for USC in order to get into the
college football playoff their resume is
really not that strong with the
exception of their wins over UCLA uh and
Notre Dame last week so uh it's a big
one and I think it's like it's tough to
beat a team twice we saw Utah take this
one earlier in the season and they're
kind of limping into this as when you
look at USC they've gotten better and
better and better you know Caleb
Williams is going to win the Heisman
Trophy he's one of the most unique
talents I've ever seen at the
quarterback position the way he
scrambles around and runs with the
football but also throws on the run on
the off platform throws and just the
entire package I mean I don't want to go
too far and
um you know say too much about his skill
set but I think you'll see NFL teams
tank for for him in the 2024 draft
because he's going to go number one
overall he's that he's that talented
special the player and he's he's got the
size he's got the ability he's got he
checks off every box you're looking for
okay if I said you could have Drake May
or Caleb Williams right now
Caleb Williams
not even a question
Caleb Williams I mean
and and it's not a question in my mind
because I've never seen anyone move the
way Caleb Williams does it's it's it's
so I don't want to call unorthodox but
because everything he does is
fundamentally sound I mean but with the
way he even moves it kind of hops within
the pocket almost like a boxer in a ring
and at the same time he's always under
control to make an accurate throw he's
got a plenty of arm uh he's a legitimate
threat when he runs he's kind of almost
like Josh Allen's lower body strength
he's really tough to bring down I mean I
was watching the Utah tape uh last night
Notre Dame going how can no one tackle
this guy I mean they've got D Lyman
who've got their arms around him they
still can't bring him down I think it's
just a credit to his overall lower body
strength but he he's he makes some
throws that you just don't see and I'm
talking even NFL level like NFL level
guys will not be able to make some of
the throws Kevin Williams can make he's
that special
um and so I would take him and it's no
disrespect to Drake may also another
very special talented kid but some of
these tools and intangibles are just
very very rare that Caleb possesses okay
if USC loses
then what
Ohio State I mean Ohio state would slide
into that next spot and I know there's
gonna be some people out there who don't
want to see that because of their recent
blowout loss to Michigan at home but up
until that point
you know their schedule wasn't the
strongest they beat Penn State on the
road we were there for that top 25 win
Notre Dame to start the season that's
not easy to start the seasons versus a
top 25 ranked team now but they
dominated their schedule I mean it
wasn't even close they were winning
games by an average margin Victory about
four touchdowns so it as much as we want
to knock them forward you play the
schedule that you make and they blew
everyone out like they should and
they're one of the most talented teams I
just think we kind of caught them uh in
a game where they probably played some
of their worst football defensively uh
in the fourth quarter of that game and
give Michigan and and Jim Harbaugh's
staff and their players credit they went
in there and they physically dominated
Ohio State a year ago this was more of
kind of demonstrating that mental
toughness of being able to beat them up
on the line of scrimmage but also
playing a tight game to the fourth
quarter and then pulling it out and just
being able to withstand the pressure and
the magnitude of that game longer
if I said Alabama and Ohio State on a
neutral field who do you think's favored
I would say Ohio state would and should
be favored now not by much
uh the difference to me though is you
know how States wide receivers
um you know you know I feel about Bryce
young Bryce Young's another special
special talented kid uh unfortunately
this year they just don't have the same
type of skill at the wide receiver
position like they've had in years past
you know Jamison Williams that you could
tell they miss him that speed that
Dynamic ability and it just it seems
like everything's been harder and the
offensive line even though all talented
players haven't played great together
collectively as a unit and they've had a
harder time protecting Bryce young this
year defensively
to make the same case they're one of the
better defenses statistically in the SEC
but this isn't you know your typical
Nick Saban defense in my opinion and
look Ohio state has their flaws too I
just think if you're putting book teams
on paper right now I'd take Ohio State
over Bama if TCU loses
then one if TC uses it it gets
interesting it puts pressure on the
college football playoff committee I
still think they should get in I I think
if you're looking at that category of
one lost teams and granted they won't
have that conference Champion but losing
to a team they already beat earlier this
season
tough to do at the Kansas State's plants
are really beautiful right now
and I think if you look at the schedule
they went through I mean at one point
Dan they played Four top 25 opponents in
fourth consecutive weeks no one else has
done that we won all of those you know
they beat five top 25 ranked teams I
think we've underestimated them the
entire season and they're a team that's
getting healthier you know Darius Davis
came back the returner wide receiver
who's their fastest player uh and a big
play maker Kendrick Miller the leading
running back came back last week Quinn
Johnston should be back for this game so
they're kind of molding into like what
you'd want to see too at this point in
time at the right time but that's a team
that I think would be a ton of fun to
see how they would Square Off versus
however this thing shakes out between
you know Georgia and Michigan who I
think we all agree are already in uh but
then those kind of next two slots and
how they're how they're spotted any
downside to the upcoming 12-team playoff
in 2024
I don't think so I mean I think the
argument that you'll get against
expansion is it dilutes what has always
been
the the best part about college football
that's the regular season you know the
the rivalries and everything else that
comes along with that and I think
there's a thought that if you expand the
playoff there's more games being played
then does it really make some of those
robbery games or some of those
conference games as important uh I mean
you could always argue the fact that
well yeah you could get a buy you could
be hosting a home game in the playoffs
like all those things still matter no
different than the NFL as the NFL still
continues to expand their playoff format
but I think it's great for the sport
honestly Dan like when I look at it I
think about some of these young men who
are opting out I mean for example pack
Tour Championship Game Savion Thomas has
already opted out it's leading Russia
for Utah that's a huge loss this last
time these two teams scored off and you
know didn't didn't have as big of an
impact but it's tough I think it limits
the amount of opt-outs that you'll see
from some of these players and I also
think it helps some of those I don't say
group of five but maybe brands that are
up there with Bama in Georgia and Ohio
State as far as being a part of it every
single year much like we look at Gonzaga
now they used to be a Cinderella story
in March Madness now they're a
Powerhouse I think you might see that
have a little bit of an impact too in
college football as well the most
important hire out of Matt rule to
Nebraska Luke fickle to Wisconsin Hugh
freeze to Auburn
give me the order of uh hires there
I think it's Matt rules to Nebraska and
only because of what that program once
was and what his track record has been
at least in college football and and
what I think it really kind of needs you
know to be quite
Frank I mean Nebraska is one of those
National brands that was an absolute
Powerhouse that I recall growing up and
I'm not saying that college football
can't live without it but it sure is a
hell a lot better when Nebraska is a
part of that conversation part of the
national conversation and I think the
Big Ten needs it more you know
Wisconsin's had their run of years where
they've been really successful and being
able to make it at least a Big Ten
championship games or winning the west
or playing a factor in all of that
Nebraska just really hasn't been
relevant since probably Beau Pelini was
there so I think that and higher is
probably more important not only to
Nebraska and their future success but
the Big Ten and what it looks like
moving forward especially if we get rid
of Divisions uh and you get some of
those you know mixture of matchups we're
going to see I think it's more important
there I I think the higher by Wisconsin
you know bringing in Luke fickle it's
not surprising that Luke Fick would want
to go there because I think it's a good
job they've obviously had some you know
success there and uh he'll do a
tremendous job recruiting and getting
that back to where I think Barry Alvarez
and the rest would would love to see it
it's just more interesting that they
went outside the box of bringing in a
former Wisconsin guy
um and that's and it kind of tells you
maybe where they're at the college
football realm right now
um and what was the third one you
mentioned but obviously few freeze to
Auburn
yeah I mean I I just I I think it's a
good hire he's a good football coach
we'll see what transpires with all of
that it's still uphill battle if you
look at the SEC West right I mean I I'm
not so sure like we saw him knock off
Bama a couple times during this time it
Ole Miss
um I think you gotta worry about bam you
gotta worry about Brian Kelly and LSU uh
you got to worry about Lane keep it a
little Miss like I don't know that I'm
putting them right away or even in the
short term future up amongst those
programs I would say they can compete
play spoiler but that's probably the
extent of where it's at right now and
and even a m who I think is really
talented we'll see what happens with
Jimbo they're not going to move on from
the buyout how big that is that's a team
that's going to come around too and it's
just it's a matter of time
always good to visit with you have a
great weekend safe travels there Brady
thanks for joining us
thanks Robin That's Brady Quinn so let
me give the uh the full
I should say introduction even though
we're saying goodbye to him the big noon
kickoff crew there in Vegas tonight the
Pac-12 title game that's at 8 Eastern
between Utah and USC then the crew will
go to Indy for the Big Ten title game
Purdue and Michigan that's tomorrow also
Brady is on Fox Sports radio's two pros
and a cup of joe which precedes our show
always great to have him on